1500 tons of good afternoon tour at
love you the 10 in four weeks
song in london des bastards elsewhere am
very happy to meet you in europe in
london adien de vie is negotiated round tine
she wants everything 5 2 you delegation
of ambassadors a game was worth it
from almeida for work and haas 5 euros
fouad various work had twelve
performances of the uk together we from
tents is even there plays ambassador's or my
but you there have you negotiations
precise text of minors oversize economic in
sochaux cros europe 1 of underworld 3  6
of drunkenness must kt responsibly
surround wildlife agreements meetings
of negative consequence to loans site
this is why say grime in woman said this
weekend to the point that a jump they are
important and where the two including
president ursula von der leyen charles
hot michel responsibilities and unity
dina grings the badge is strong from next
seven years and very abichou recovery
speaking yuping plan betting
all say from january 19  r begin with
a few words of context different offer
high level meeting president on saône in
order to ryan with his solid charles
michel in june the trail minister boris
johnson towers latin title reach
apolitical the crane mantis quickly the case
minister rise at the free ride stadium in
nahrwan  we are all from the open
cortade justice from uk does not have all of
wright 2 ends future uequeloz
without against years to drums a citrus
fruits heaps of things to brax it makes
real difference that we lose everything
existing if you fail them  10 mn law
boris johnson wright 16 matters said it all
or twice
following the rivals meeting where ingrid
everything intensified hour disc thing
we have tried to understand why try
protestant at 10 rue redline can be
squared with our commitment little
understanding new partnership at 7 at
haute et de politique elle decoration
signed by minsk johnson en de
seventeen
havok tour de last year picot darcos et
ni international citrus fruits increase
constrain  t parti toudeh des youyous de
morobe du s au jack and we have continued
d'une guedj sincerely and constructive
lies in line with the band and given to a
smile from ma b states with the support of
the human palm harbor over the past few
weeks  from uk has not hot serve the
commitment values
i nastou fine solution respecting funda
ental dinghies main inter
st of this week with constructive disc
omething halfway goods and surre
south vadis
negotiations complex art and w
cry is unique progress a cross all a
l  this week
discussion any specific case we positive
atmosphere 25 david frost india esteem in
douala you you team ford and
professionals approach to
professionals approach and aude
did you mix we progress then in houston
discussion turned raw power diversity
coordination 1 union program
yes  but you are progressing comprehensive objective towers
in single institutional
fact morocco cloud
rob is a force same mechanism and we
have good  discussions in police judy chu
cooperation event deiser jones rim is
an all important objective transport
energy we are in time is useful disc
thing happens during look and continue
or tories quest single market like
benefix more sad they
appear to us our provinces in all
essentials  topix power like economic
partnership first msb robust guarantees
strong level price fields including state
and from a stand at this point open day
to compete in my case web business
paul orssaud vertal here the body
interest for all 36 bernabé states and
my view also for  the uk seconds
we have a great and balanced
steinbourg long-term solutions for fisheries is
interested in freedoms
in mind and up list of mini leads a
band where art and rough living
the eee pad on it on food sykes the
design  of the group in china notes as
asus or prince
we have been sing sing sing sing very
big in negotiations
our idea eyes costantini over of the
laughing one has to  mansion explicitly in
the political decoration razer pretext
women de framework de basic two
founders framework of death
negotiations for h&m the dough about
to have politics the commitment the spirit
minister boris johnson
eight months ago we are simply asking
simply asking everything france les  10
deputy hallynck politics into league
text
nothing more on stage your prime
minister rights and 16 gentle nature of
all alike mansion to develop a
line of a record or is this weekend and
uk 10.9 shoah willingness to break
deadlock on develops a  field de uk
refuses in any case mitchum anthony hayes
stand up in meaningful way and state aid
assistance of customers wording of
politics young people want to clear you have
progressed us wrongly from 6 or from moring
because we have no visibility a mourning
or care intention  future domestic it
was 10 control system and regime
i respect and uk politics of the bec of
time for answers of french size
risk weekl  y running out important
here is the climate and damned les beaux
un sous sol l'eau
de uk refused indeed in the void
hunter cutting bachelor in tongues uk
one star game it rule authorizes
autonomy ok we respect at your
rock camp say 'we rule  internal
an autonomy of 10 all competitions
luiz as we have to answer discretion to
him comic you new economic partnership
burning outraged at uk freephone tax free
form quotas this pathos to fruits
form competing in hockey
business ones that to the uk such space
and  need some tea for its business is
canadian hockey of price
or long term uncertain ti saying
advantageous false our business and day where
i respect and uk government's policy
joyce el oued where no solution of you
cannot accept and will not accept
bill ford football  and uk politics
joris albi very clear that may be there
is clear less ambitious embellishing
goods and services 2009 the idi you to
drop in the dem  on's forge east lake and
anne fischer and the duke the numbers of
as it provides a total excludes young
girls or phishing paid to families
which brings everyone an acceptable price from
uk where they become independent
coastal state in diouf or respect them
and we  will rock you under of futura
grint term ebit changes all of benefit
of uk
fischer like stoxx need to be managed
yellow cries accordingly
intenationaux water
one of the main love responsible
investment management of resources to
enemies agreements than to our bed more
per day
destruction  from wuxi china industry rip
it we have to grid and balanced
buy long term leases
solution faux fisheries protecting from
mad men and women use livelihood depend
on is the human designer from you
always in cistude from an economic
partnership from uk est  include robust
level playing field red to danic
witbooi citrus anton sheet at 10 min
simplet dabye 49 use to commit
conditions open for competition  and
balanced citrus maiden darling of
uk mix trade agreement has gone
a writing until the very wide coast
of the negotiations clues straw of heart
in difficulty of you will remain in game
constructive a respect too ineffective
of uk has chosen to leave of single
market maker  theme union en de frost
january next year in little more
of infamous times years
this will bring inevitable just want to
nawa said we are getting ready fabris
communication a few days ago erp and
citizens business in public
administration ripert must des indes de
leader period transition with
grid 10 week of five billion euros
special brick instruments site
adjustment reaser de canter in force
india happy consequence
hinman states and ottawa sector
affected the rexy a parallel then to
sofia public over next i seventy
specific sectors our  ex testers
do they say what action to the
referees and 15,000 sector would double 10
Marseille from t  ransition
disney period this is a man of the tories reading
force rare 2d sets and volley ball and
our uk task force web php object sli
ladies and gentlemen we do not great
shenae grimes and if you sweat and women
and our future partnership d' avril by
far  more friction fringes in a
good trading in addition to newcastle formalities
of will be dried up a quota this gesture of
all orders etc if you all decide to
brac indian site will continue to tell
of all it is necessary to glimpse additional
friction you but when the
mannequin grid october  eastern time
soudas also reiterated that she endorses
everything flirting force giannoli texture
this means that we all i have a few weeks
left and that which would not west tel
this best series made you know we
only have little time a college  from
sentheim all about printers from
withdraw agreements together with two
vice chairmen of commissions maros
sefcovic we continue to follow closely
implementation lease from uk of its
ungrateful commitment of protocol in island
and north said nothing this context of the
leader before the gray care in the world
of the webs to the quests one hundred 1.6
million euros 2.2 pis place program
in support of peace in addition to that the
things
one to continue his future his butt
border co princes in l1
dorine special door committee
colonna island news flow that a young
texting progress live like to 5 michael
gove indices team for the ring n' roll
but we mean concern t'a  given it is
that of jose will not been pressure from
first of january 28 manyu diaries we
grace period need our own
ordis implementation india protocol
it was going to our swimmers who topic of the
wild world women vigilante together we
the 36 value governments and the
european  by the lack of guarantees of
rights of british national cover
badwill of logs in living in one
conditioning baystate of sentheim
knows it - week specter rights of you need
is love in the uk to be its guard  s
today the designers human it
gives them a grand tour to furnes from yooz
willingness to reach an ambitious
partnership a dream in all i was
including even the exterior e-tron
security and defense her when you have
your daddy this piece of wish of de
presents
ursula von der leyen charles michel
rioux par l'anc 12.6 seven et 2 tango
valse continue to believe that ramiste
bruce johnson one of the uk government's
want to find agreements with you because
it is simply innauer comme interest to
cover est en toi drees
mais ni  a very serious challenger everything
of today climate change and biodiversity
and security research and innovation
democracy is fundamental rights of
fight against poverty and financial
stability
if i'm famous live from saint-exupéry
negotiations he just notes to look
in all this pic at one another  10 to look
to gather in de sem direction à will be
back in london with my team next week as
planned for in mid auguste voir
continue à l'horizon remains i  n chains
regime
when we talk about state aid
we are at the heart of a very serious and
very serious subject for us I believe that for
the British which is that of the
conditions to ensure what we
call open to a competitive sphere
of  fair trade and
is open, which I believe is useful and
necessary for everyone, not
only for businesses but
also for consumers, and
at the heart of this issue
we need open competition we
need a robust system
control of state aid on both
sides and a form of consistency
or equivalence between our systems
provided that it exists and that is the
problem we have today
we had to  the european union
state aid regime which is well known that
the united kingdom knows well and that it will
leave on december 31st and
we europeans need to know the
future british system of what is
called aid regime  state
debts so this is the request we
are making to see things clearly and be able to
work on one of the key points of this
level playing field in terms
of state debts I understand that's what
voids told me  that the united kingdom is in
the middle of a debate on this issue at
government level at parliament level
we understand the time needed for
this debate but we must strive to get this
debate done quickly enough for
us to see it clearly when we
conclude  this negotiation
first of all we are here about a negotiation
which is very serious very complex
much more complex than some
people think
with many two consequences
me I am not this word of bring the
cheap
I do not believe in this  method in such a
complex negotiation moreover
I observe that in all
trade negotiations and the
European Union we have conducted a lot and
even recently with Japan South Korea
or Canada the United Kingdom have
c  we are currently driving with the
united states new
zealand australia or japan
we are not proceeding with this this method
there of mist and cheap
it is too serious a matter if i may say so
we have to build  a
lasting partnership between the UK economy and
the European economy which are among
the most active and dynamic economies in
the world with
innumerable consequences for improving
if we succeed the life the work
of businesses and consumers
all that does not  don't improvise and all of this
isn't done under threat or
ultimatums so I've never seen a
negotiation run this way and
I think we don't have time
for this kind of game here I'm trying to
chernozem after making risk
there are risks to our deals
objectively as long as the
british positions on two
important points which are at the heart of the
interests of the demands of the
european union in this  you negotiating
the level ping wire which concerns the
whole economy of the European Union and 27
countries
and obviously the question of fishing
as long as British needs
are blocked that
we will not have a reciprocal opening
compared to the openings that  I have
dismissed the European case on subjects which
are subjects of British interest
so there is an objective risk of our 10
here I must remind you that on the two
subjects which I have just mentioned as
on others the  global governance respect
for certain fundamental principles in
terms of police and
judicial cooperation for the protection of
citizens
the european positions are not
tactical or short-term positions
they are serious fundamental positions
and we must find dynamic compromises
on this subject as has been  said
our president ursula von der leyen
a few weeks ago we are ready to
negotiate until the last toy
what do i  i can tell chris
morris through this camera that what
he feels about me is the
exact opposite of the truth
as far as i'm concerned it's one thing
that's true it's never
been  enthusiastic about the break if you were
n't surprised I've always said
no one has been able to
show you the slightest added value of the
break site but it's a reality
the institutional and political break site
is now realized I point
out  to chris morris that it was
carried out in an orderly fashion thanks to adil
that we signed with the first
boris johnson and that was ratified by
the house of commons wants by the
british parliament and by the
european parliament
me it's been four years that I am  that
i have the honor of leading this
negotiation on behalf of the european union
with all the teams of the
european commission and i am working for an
agreement
i am working for an orderly site break
they have made part of the journey  n big
part of the way with
regard to the institutional and
political divorce we now have to
organize to succeed it is my objective
an adil agreement on the break
economic and commercial sites but for
the moment we are not there
the match
c  Isn't that
how complex negotiations happen?
I actually did a few
weeks ago in the context of respecting my
opening mandate on what I
recalled earlier in my
street opening  marx the three red lines indicated
personally by dow jones home on
the coast justice british sovereignty with
regard to these laws and on fishing
before going further we expect
reciprocal openness on the subjects which
are those where the european union has  marked
since the beginning of priorities which
once again are not
tactical or cyclical priorities, therefore the
moment when the British who will come
to us with a real desire to
compromise on these su  important jets for
the european union as we are
ready confirmed that we are going to
them on matters of importance for the
united kingdom so very frankly i
say to them it will not take much
time to consolidate these
dynamic compromises by means of  texts by the way, I
remind you that in March
we put the text on the right
sweety table almost completely on the other
side the British have also done a very
big job to present
legal texts
so for the drafting of the texts from
the  now we agree we
do not need a lot of
time provided we have the sincere
and unambiguous bases of a compromise and an
agreement between us
these are multiple and different questions
frankly I first  I read the
articles of the British press
very carefully it is always very
stimulating to read the British press
but you should not believe everything that is
written in any case it does not correspond  spond not
always to the truth and with regard to the
point raised by lisa or 40 has never
been question we say on the side of david
frost nor on my side to abandon the
negotiation it is precisely the
opposite we want to intensify
we try  we do not always get close
enough and we
continue to clarify to confront our
points of view and has worked or
has progress been made there is
progress or real convergence on
certain subjects such as the coordination of
social security land or  the
programs of the union these are important subjects
my head was
addressed to me it was addressed a
few days ago on cooperation in
university matters erasmus research these
are subjects where we intelligently
we must cooperate for the good  common
in the coming times and we
have offered to the united kingdom as
do for other third countries
norway switzerland to cooperate with us
in the case of bram horizon sur  the
research questions in the
erasmus program for the court of justice
i said that we were ready to
look for a way with a certain
flexibility not to make
systematic reference to the court since
the british do not want at all
that is what  that Maurice johnson obviously told us
the price to be paid will be without
consequence to reduce the scope of cooperation
in certain areas I take
the example of certain points of
cooperation in judicial and police matters
and I will regret it but it is one
of the  consequences of the
British request concerning the court of
justice
we have in certain specific areas
the obligation to make a reference to the
court of justice when it comes to
the interpretation of European law
for the protection of citizens' rights
I cannot  not do otherwise
so if we do not want the court of
justice probably we will be led on
certain subjects to reduce the scope of
our cooperation
affecting them  cost the protocol on
northern ireland and ireland is very
precise it is no longer a text that needs to
be renegotiated it has been negotiated
it has been ratified approved by the house
of commons the british government
and the european parliament the  leaders
of the european union
and now it is a question of implementing it
methodically in a concrete way by
de-dramatizing the subjects in an
operational way to preserve what has been
for me the most important since the
beginning in this negotiation because it is
not  it's not about the
goods of the technical trade, it
's about the men and women who
live in ireland who
remember this very hard conflict on an island where
peace is fragile and therefore our
responsibility for the kingdom  united and
for us with obviously with
regard to the european union the
government of dublin
it is to preserve the conditions of
this peace but here is in what spirit
we negotiated with the  two
successive governments in the united kingdom
and finally with dwayne johnson this
protocol on ireland and northern ireland
so i thanked
earlier michael gove and his team because i
think we are going british and
sincerely committed to
implement this agreement for ireland
I know it's sensitive I know
it's difficult we have moreover
decided to cooperate only with British interests
, particularly for checks
and control in belfast and we are going to
do it in a way
open and constructive simply we
are vigilant because time
flies and there are technical provisions
of the infrastructures of the
also legal conditions which must
be regulated week after week so
that the treaty with regard to the protocol
ireland is effectively operational
on 31  next december which 20 games
and expressionism
i said all looks happy as if
british positions on major topics
po  ur the European Union does
not move a trade agreement becomes
improbable it is very difficult if the
British positions move as we
have moved on certain subjects so if
I may say
the October deadline and is not
only realistic it is necessary
because we must not keep these
two months of November and December at the end
for technical problems,
translations, for example, into all the
languages of the European Union and not just
nglish, and for the proce
s of ratification by the Europ
an Parliament and  we have to
respect the time needed for the
European parliament that we respect
the time needed for the
UK parliament so I hope that the
positions will move in the right
direction
and if so the October deadline
and it is necessary that  it's the
last that when we can
make a deal
i repeat because these two
col 2 battles everything but break site
we have to prepare  er to
very important changes which are the
automatic mechanical consequence of the
bric site in any event on
January 1st
the simple fact that all the
goods which will come from the
United Kingdom anywhere in the single
European market must be controlled it is a
considerable change in the same
way all the goods which
will come from the european union within
the united kingdom having to be checked
normally the case we are preparing for
these checks and the thousands of
additional customs posts have been
created from veterinary posts to
countries  low in belgium in france in
ireland and in other countries so it is
a very important change in any
case the i would like to say once again
that the cumulative effect of these checks
which are compulsory which are the
reality of next january 1st  the
cumulative effect of these controls
with possible
additional pricing constraints on
all such goods  es and quotas if
we don't have a trade agreement
it's an
extremely serious cumulative effect for many
sectors that's me I don't work
for I noted one is a skinny deal
I'm not betraying  not for that i am
not even working for a gray look but we are
working
with first the sooner we can
conclude the better it will be in
the experience of
four years negotiations with the uk is that
every day counts  it when it will be necessary to
finalize our agreement in October
perhaps at the end of October all the hours
will also count provided
that we have done most of the work because
we are working on a text which will
have 500,600 pages it is a
legal text  we are talking about who protects
who gives guarantees on both sides
to institutions to citizens to
companies
good then the blame game which evokes that
yanis we know him well
I have never been impressed by this
pale game I have always thought  that those
who played this game of the bling game
were wasting their time and as there is
not much time to waste
I recommend that knows this kind
of argument we have brought our
points of view closer on many subjects
we have the same objective  I believe
in an ambitious and intelligent agreement
in many areas, even if I
regret that we do not cover all the
areas that are set out in the
political declaration, in particular
foreign policy, defense perhaps
that will come later, I simply hope so
we respect the
British positions which must respect the
we respect sovereignty
must respect another we must
find points of
compromise agrees that I simply repeat that with
regard to the conditions of entry into
our European market and the market of
450 million consumers regarding
entry requirements for
UK goods for
UK services including
fi  nancial for state for
people for
uk businesses we set the
conditions of entry no one else
that's it that's our sovereignty
we respect
british sovereignty equally so I am
convinced that an agreement is possible and
we are working for an agreement even
if today it is difficult
at first i would like to repeat extremely
clearly and in a very sincere way
that i have a lot of respect for
david frost for the team  British
as a whole of an extremely
professional and competent team
that does not surprise us because we
know the quality of
the British administration and I
respect the whole of the
British team which is opposite us and
which works under  the authority and with the
confidence of boris johnson when
negotiating as i have the honor to do
on behalf of a european with the
british government is my side
under the control of the board and  of
the President of the Commission and of
Parliament,
we listen to and respect what the
first Briton says and that's what
matters to us and to me, so I
listen and I respect, but I don't take into
account what he says.  the first
British
I don't know where
the information is still filed I moreover got his
article yesterday morning in the telegraph the
timetable on which we are working
was set by mutual agreement more
than a month ago and  so the work
session we have which is not a rand
next week i will be back in
london with the 5 teams is
set over a month ago
seen so yes we will meet again
next week
it is a need  common and then
alternatively in brussels
and here the next one will be
from august 17th to the middle of next august
and in the meantime even if i
tell a gordon i'm obviously going 30
some days family vacation
like him no doubt  [ __ ] you
want to  e take a few days like
david frost
we will continue to be working
always available call to move forward
on the topics and prepare for the next
round of August 17 because once
again time is running out and every day
every week is weeks
is always useful  to come to an
agreement at the
point of concluding
[Music]